Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Todos los días de tu vida,
te mueves en sistemas de poder
que otras personas crearon.
¿Los detectas?
¿Entiendes el poder?
¿Te das cuenta por qué es importante?
El poder es algo que a menudo
nos incomoda cuando hablamos de él.
Eso es especialmente cierto en la vida
cívica, por vivir juntos en comunidad.
En una democracia, el poder se supone
que debe residir en las personas, punto.
Cualquier otra charla sobre el poder
y quién realmente lo tiene
parece un tanto obsceno,
tal vez incluso maligno.
Pero el poder no es intrínsecamente
mejor o peor que el fuego o la física.
Simplemente es.
Gobierna cómo
cualquier gobierno funciona.
Determina quién determinará
las reglas del juego.
Así que aprender cómo funciona el poder
es clave para ser eficaz,
para ser tomado en serio,
y para que no se aprovechen de uno.
En esta lección,
veremos de dónde viene el poder,
cómo se ejerce y qué se puede hacer
para ser más poderoso en la vida pública.
Vamos a empezar
con una definición básica.
Poder es la capacidad de hacer que los
demás hagan lo que te gustaría.
Por supuesto, esto aplica
en todos los ámbitos de la vida,
desde la familia, el lugar de trabajo,
hasta en nuestras relaciones.
Nos centraremos en el ámbito cívico,
donde el poder significa conseguir
que una comunidad tome decisiones
y que tome las acciones que deseas.
Hay seis fuentes principales
de poder cívico.
La 1º forma es la fuerza física
y la capacidad para la violencia.
El control de los instrumentos
de fuerza, ya sea policial o militar,
es el poder
en su forma más primaria.
Una 2ª fuente principal
del poder es la riqueza.
El dinero posibilita comprar resultados y
comprar casi cualquier otro tipo de poder.
La 3ª forma de poder es
la acción del Estado, del gobierno.
Es usar la ley y burocracia
para obligar a las personas
a que hagan o no ciertas cosas.
En una democracia, por ejemplo,
nosotros, el pueblo, en teoría,
damos al gobierno su poder
a través de elecciones.
En una dictadura, el poder del Estado
surge de la amenaza de la fuerza,
y no del consentimiento
de los gobernados.
El 4º tipo son las normas sociales o lo
que otros piensan que está bien.
Las normas no tienen la maquinaria
centralizada de gobierno.
Operan de manera más suave,
de igual a igual.
Pueden hacer que las personas cambien
el comportamiento e incluso las leyes.
Piensa cómo han ido evolucionando las
normas de la igualdad en el matrimonio.
La 5ª forma de poder son las ideas.
Una idea, las libertades individuales,
por ejemplo, o la igualdad racial,
puede generar
cantidades ilimitadas de poder
si se motiva suficientemente a la gente
para cambiar su pensamiento y acciones.
Y así la 6ª fuente de poder es
el número, un montón de humanos.
Una masa vocal de la gente
crea poder expresando
intereses colectivos con intensidad
y afirmando la legitimidad.
Piensa en la Primavera Árabe
o el ascenso del Tea Party.
La multitud cuenta.
Estas son las seis principales
fuentes de poder, lo que es el poder.
Así que ahora, pensemos
en cómo funciona el poder.
Hay tres leyes del poder
que vale la pena examinar.
Ley número 1:
El poder nunca es estático.
Está siempre aumentando o
descomponiéndose en un escenario cívico.
Así que si no actúas,
alguien lo hace por ti.
Ley número 2:
El poder es como el agua.
Fluye como una corriente
a través de la vida cotidiana.
La política es la tarea de aprovechar
ese flujo en la dirección que prefieras.
Formular políticas es un esfuerzo para
congelar y perpetuar
un flujo particular de poder.
La política es poder congelado.
Ley número 3:
el poder se forma.
El poder engendra más poder
y lo mismo ocurre con la falta de poder.
Lo único que mantiene la ley número 3
liderando una situación
donde solo una persona
tiene todo el poder
depende de cómo aplicamos
las leyes 1 y 2.
¿Qué reglas hemos creado para que algunas
personas no acumulen demasiado poder,
y por tanto que no consagren
sus privilegios en la política?
Esa es el punto de la democracia,
y se puede ver cada una de estas leyes
en el trabajo, en cualquier noticia.
Los trabajadores se organizan
por mejores salarios.
Las petroleras presionan por la
aprobación de un oleoducto.
Parejas gay y lesbianas buscan
el derecho legal de casarse.
Padres urbanos exigen vales escolares.
Tú puedes apoyar estos esfuerzos o no.
Conseguir lo que quieres depende
de lo hábil que seas con el poder,
lo que nos lleva, a lo que puedes hacer
para ser más poderoso en la vida pública.
Aquí, es útil pensar en
términos de alfabetización.
Tu reto es aprender
a leer poder y escribir poder.
Leer poder significa prestar atención
a todos los textos de poder que puedas.
No me refiero solo a libros.
Me refiero a ver la sociedad
como un conjunto de textos.
¿No te gusta cómo son las cosas
en tu campus o en tu ciudad o país?
Analiza quién tiene qué tipo de poder,
arraigado en qué sistemas.
Entiende por qué
se desarrolló de esta manera,
quién lo hizo así
y quién quiere mantenerlo así.
Estudia las estrategias que
otros utilizan en estas situaciones:
ataque frontal o indirecto,
coaliciones o autoridad carismática.
Lee para poder escribir.
Escribir con poder requiere primero que
creas que tienes el derecho a escribir,
para ser un autor de cambio.
Hazlo.
Al igual que con todo tipo de escritura,
tú aprendes a expresarte,
a hablar con una voz auténtica.
Organiza tus ideas,
luego organiza a otras personas.
Practica la creación de consenso.
Práctica el conflicto.
Al igual que con la escritura,
es todo cuestión de práctica.
Todos los días tienes la oportunidad
de practicar, en tu vecindario y más allá.
Establece objetivos,
luego otros mayores.
Mira los patrones,
observa qué funciona.
Adapta, repite.
Esta es la ciudadanía.
En esta breve lección, hemos visto
de dónde viene el poder cívico,
cómo funciona y
qué puedes hacer para ejercerlo.
Una gran pregunta pendiente
es el "por qué" del poder.
¿Quieres poder para beneficiar
a todo el mundo o solo a ti?
¿Son sus propósitos
prosociales o antisociales?
Esta pregunta no es sobre estrategia.
Es sobre carácter,
y eso es para otra serie de lecciones.
Pero recuerda esto:
El poder junto con el carácter
es igual a un gran ciudadano,
y tú tienes el poder de ser uno.